in this video it might be a little bit
dense to kind of go through but we're
gonna talk about glycogen synthesis what
is glycogen synthesis glycogen synthesis
is making like a gin from glucose or
basically we're storing glucose so when
we when would we want glycogen synthesis
to occur when would we want to store
glucose well when we have high
concentrations of glucose right that
would be a good time if because we have
too much of it we might want to store it
or higher level levels of ATP
essentially what that is is during high
energy up during high energy states
during high energy states that's when we
want to store the energy if we have too
much energy around let's store it let's
let's take all this glucose and store it
somewhere so if you recall glucose
6-phosphate from which pathway this was
this was this was actually from
glycolysis right if we have glucose
6-phosphate
and we add this enzyme
phosphoglucomutase what this enzyme does
is it I summarized this glucose
6-phosphate and just moves this
phosphate group over to the one the the
one carbon so age group and turns it
into glucose 1-phosphate this is needed
for glycogen synthesis which is why I
actually just mentioned it here so how
is it needed
essentially this glucose 1-phosphate
needs to be activated before we can even
actually put it into a glycation chain
so before we can make like acidic bonds
with this g1p we need to activate it so
this this reaction that i'm about to
discuss here is to about the activation
of glucose 1-phosphate
so glucose 1-phosphate comes along and
this thing called uridine triphosphate
which is a primitive nucleotide comes in
and then what we have happen is this
this your adenine this plus this first
phosphate group here end up attaching to
this phosphate on the g1p
so what we get is this uridine and we
have these two phosphates
and then we have glucose so we call this
thing is UDP which is right here u DP
diphosphate glucose or UDP G what do we
have left over is just these two
phosphate groups here
those two phosphate groups here exist as
this thing here which is called a
pyrophosphate inorganic pyrophosphate
so this inorganic pyrophosphate can be
hydrolyzed into two individual inorganic
phosphate groups and that actually
drives this reaction forward so the
energetics here we have G 1p and UTP to
form UDP g and this pyrophosphate that's
actually a reaction that's active
equilibrium it's I so energetic
whereas this the pyrophosphate being
hydrolyzed into the two two inorganic
phosphate groups has a negative free
energy which means it's a spontaneous
process and therefore is exergonic right
exergonic or spontaneous right so this
power is the production of UDP G excuse
me
now I reason I put a pink star here over
the hydrolysis of this pyrophosphate and
the reason why is because it's very
common in metabolic processes for a
pyrophosphate hydrolysis to power or
drive a particular reaction so I kind of
wanted to give you guys a heads up for
that um so but why do we do this why is
this whole why do we why do we do this
why do we why wouldn't we just add this
g1p to a carbon or to a glycogen chain
excuse me the reason why is because UDP
is having this UDP on here instead of
just this phosphate this UDP is a better
leaving group then the phosphate group
which brings me to my next point about
the enzyme glycogen synthase so glycogen
synthase quite simply is the maker of
glycogen it's the thing that makes like
again when would it be active well we
mentioned earlier that we would want it
to be active during high energy states
right because Vicodin synthase is a
storing storing glucose as glycogen so
you want to only store glucose when we
already have plenty of it around we have
plenty of energy high energy states
so what glycogen synthase does it
actually catalyzes a very particular
reaction the reaction that it catalyzes
is it adds a glucose unit in the form of
UDP G which we just
created above or just a moment ago to an
existing glycogen chain so it makes a
glycogen chain one glucose unit longer
so how exactly does it do that let's
think about this this is the UDP G that
we just created here this glucose with
this uridine diphosphate UDP glucose now
this here is what I've drawn here is a
glycogen chain that's n residues in
length
I've only draw two residues here because
I didn't want to spend too much time
drawing out a bunch of different
glucoses but you can imagine that this
chain goes on further and further and
further which is actually why I drew
this o R here it indicates the
continuation of this polymer sort of in
this direction to the right excuse me
so what happens what is the reaction
that glycogen synthase catalyzes well we
want this glucose right we want this
glucose here to be attached to this
glycogen chain at the non-reducing end
which you mentioned in the previous
video so what happens is this OAH group
here it acts as a nucleophile to attack
this carbon right is a nucleophilic
attack and then what happens is the
electrons from this bond attack onto the
phosphate and then UDP hops off so what
ends up happening is we form a covalent
bond between between this glucose and
this glucose here from the glycogen
chain excuse me again I'm sorry about
that
this UDP hops off it's it's it's free
it's it no longer bound but this glucose
here which I've indicated in yellow has
been attached to the existing chain
which was already here in white so this
here is of course a particular
glycosidic linkage it is an alpha 1-4
glycosidic linkage so that's what like
the glycogen synthase actually does is
it forms these alpha 1-4 glycosidic
linkages so now this glycogen chain is n
plus 1 residues in length it's one
glucose longer than it was before so I
mentioned that uridine diphosphate is a
better leaving group than the one
phosphate group and so it allows this
reaction to happen more readily which is
why we even attach the uridine
diphosphate in the first place
so hopefully that makes sense there so
selection synthase this is how it
actually adds another glucose molecule
to an existing glycogen chain now
as a brief sort of mention we mentioned
earlier that we so basically what
happens actually is once we have these
this UDP right if we want this reaction
to continue if you want glycogen
synthase to actually do this again
catalyze this reaction again then what
we need is we need to activate another
glucose 1-phosphate we need this
reaction to happen again so that we can
create another UDP Jie that we can
attach to the glycogen chain well in
order to do that we need another UTP
right so this UDP right comes together
with an ATP too and basically the ATP
gives the UTP its phosphates or the UDP
a phosphate so this is you this heading
has two phosphate groups ATP has three
phosphate groups this ATP gives up a
phosphate to the UDP to regenerate UTP
and then we're left with an ADP so the
purpose of this is we must regenerate
UTP to continue to synthesize glycogen
right we need to create more UDP G's so
we need more UTP s around right we need
more of these so that we could have this
reaction occur again right this is a
requirement here for that activation
step it's a little bit more if you're
interested glycogen synthase where you
just mentioned this it only adds glucose
is to an existing chain and that
existing chain has to be at least at
least eight glucose as long
so really glycogen synthase is involved
in the elongation of an existing
glycogen chain how does it begin well
that's where glycogenin comes in
so glycogenin it generates glycogen so
it actually initiates glycogen synthesis
after it initiates glycogen synthesis
then glycogen synthase takes over to
elongate so glycogen is religious
involved in initiation in addition in
the last video we talked about how there
were branches on glycogen so there is
the this enzyme called the branching
enzyme and what it does is it takes
about six residues six glucose residues
at a time from the non-reducing end of
an existing chain and it takes those
those six residues and attaches and
attaches them at branch points
via alpha 1-4 force to me alpha 1:6
linkages so that's the sort of summary
of what goes on with packaging synthesis
I hope that was helpful even if it was a
little bit dense maybe you should go
back and pause the video and do whatever
you need to do to understand this stuff
I hope that was helpful thanks for
watching